one of the most mysterious games out
there cyberpunk 2077 finally reemerged
with a recent one-word tweet it's a very
small thing but it most likely indicates
the developers CD Projekt RED will be
giving us an update on the game soon
however not all games are so lucky there
are quite a few that we've heard very
little about in years some announced
ages ago and others only hinted out with
no official word these games haven't
been cancelled outright either leaving
them in limbo from the Final Fantasy 7
remake to Borderlands 3 these are the
games we're still waiting to hear more
or anything about you probably remember
that a Final Fantasy 7 remake is
happening but it's faded into the
background in recent months it was
announced at Sony's e3 2015 press
conference and we even saw a gameplay
trailer later that year there was also
an interview in March 2017 with director
Tetsuya Nomura that details some
gameplay systems including stealth and
taking cover the last bit of news came
in May 2017 when it was revealed that
Square Enix would be developing the game
internally
since then we've heard nothing at all
back in 2015 Pikmin 4 was announced and
apparently very close to completion
after almost a year with no news
Miyamoto of himself assured Pikmin fans
the sequel was still happening and that
was it
though spin-off hey Pikmin came out on
3ds last year it's not at all clear
what's happening with Pikmin for besides
the fact that it's well happening
phantom dust has entered its fourth year
running on our missing games list with
no sign of news anytime soon the reboot
of the 2005 Xbox game is the same name
was first announced at e3 2014 but its
original developer darkside game studios
closed down following February we saw
some leaked gameplay footage in 2015 and
got confirmation of the game wasn't dead
but we still haven't heard anything
since that said a separate phantom dust
re-release with slight improvements
arrived in May 2017 Tekken cross street
fighter was announced in 2010 for ps3
and xbox 360 and it's been kind of a
mystery ever since producer Katsuhiro
Harada assured fans in 2014 and
reiterated in 2015 that the crossover
fighting game wasn't cancelled however
in April 2016 Harada revealed that
Tekken cross street fighter was no
longer in active development and that
publisher Bandai Namco was waiting for
the right time to release it when asked
for a comment Bandai Namco told us the
tekken team is focused on Tekken 7 DLC
which means we probably will have to
wait a little bit longer for an update
on the crossover
zombie survival game Dead Island 2 came
out of the gate with a very memorable
trailer at e3 2014 and memorable is good
since we've heard so little since the
game's original spring 2015 release
window was later delayed to 2016 and
then it lost its developer Jaeger in
July 2015
still publisher Deep Silver assured us
it wasn't cancelled there's been no news
on Dead Island 2 since March 2016 when
it was announced that LittleBigPlanet 3
developers sumo digital had taken over
at the games development
now in its third year on our missing
games list ps4 souls like deep down was
revealed in 2013 it didn't disappear
right away we got details and trailers
up through TGS 2014 and it was supposed
to have a public beta in early 2015 the
beta never happened and in a February
2015 interview producer Yoshinori Ono
said that the game wasn't cancelled that
might be reworked in 2016 capcom told us
that a Western release was never even
confirmed for deep-down but the
publisher filed a new patent for the
game in the u.s. in early 2017 it
remains to be seen if the game comes -
westwards but even the Japanese version
has been out of the news for quite a
while
it wouldn't be a missing games list
without agent the cold war-era espionage
game was teased way way back in 2007 and
announced in 2009 as a ps3 exclusive
from Grand Theft Auto developer Rockstar
North since then the game hasn't been
cancelled but it's barely more than a
murmur the first images from agent were
teased in 2011 when Rockstar parent take
to confirmed the game was still in
development two full years later take to
renew the trademarks for agent and
renewed the trademarks again in 2014
just before e3 new images emerge in 2015
at the end of 2016
take 2 refiled the agent trademarks yet
again since then there's been silence
but it's still not cancelled
what's being called Borderlands 3 hasn't
actually been announced but it's been
heavily hinted at in January 2015
gearbox CEO Randy Pitchford tweeted that
the developer was recruiting for the
next Borderlands game he specifically
said that it was the big one since then
pitchford has continued to dance around
an official announcement he instead gave
a few more details in April 2016 and
confirmed that it was in the works and
he tweets sly hints from time to time
we pretty much have to mention half-life
3 even long after it hit peak meme
status and transcended to the realm of
never going to happen
half-life 2 episode 3 was announced back
in 2006 but never materialized but it
also wasn't canceled in a reddit AMA in
early 2017 valve boss gabe newell's that
there was still a possibility of more
games in the half-life portal universe
so that's something and there's also the
lead story summary from former valve
writer Marc Laidlaw
which confirms nothing but is a wild
read these are only a few of the games
that have gone missing for the full list
check out GameSpot calm and let us know
in the comments what games you're
looking forward to hearing more about
this year
[Music]